[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es einen basic rezept
wir werden wie nach schlitz machen ich
glaube darauf haben wirklich schon viele
gewartet
ein wiener schnitzel ist ein schnitzel
aus kalbsfleisch auch regional
österreichisch und die kunst darin aber
die kunst besteht darin dass die panade
schön luftig wird und schnitzel einfach
mega gut schmeckt und heute zeige ich
euch wie ich das zu hause mache ich habe
übrigens schon einen kartoffelsalat
vorbereitet denn wir essen gerne
kartoffelsalat dazu gut wenn wir
auswärts essen sind dann bestelle ich
auch gerne pommes dazu auch pommes mache
ich daher eigentlich nie deswegen eher
kartoffelsalat da gibt's das rezept
schon auf meinem blog und den habe ich
jetzt bereits gestern abend schon
zubereitet und einfach bei
raumtemperatur stehen lassen denn
kartoffelsalat aus dem kühlschrank das
mag ich nicht und ich habe ich jetzt die
zutaten fürs schnitzel
ich werde das schnitzel zubereiten also
wenn ihr weniger seite dann einfach die
menge halbieren und zwar nehme ich jetzt
hier acht kalbsschnitzel etwas salz und
pfeffer ich habe ich etwas mehl dreier 3
esslöffel sahne wir sind ungefähr 30 g
semmelbrösel etwas öl dann nämlich ein
sonnenblumenöl oder ihr könnt auch
butterschmalz nehmen wichtig ist einfach
dass er entdeckt habt was ihr wirklich
schön hoch erhitzen könnt was aber
trotzdem relativ geschmacksneutral ist
wobei ich den buttergeschmack im
butterschmalz sehr mag deswegen nehme
ich es vielleicht gleich noch dazu
das erste was ich jetzt mache ist ich
habe das kalbsfleisch zum zuschneiden
lassen und jetzt jetzt einfach noch ein
bisschen platt geklopft und das mache
ich jetzt mit zu einem fleischklopfer
zwischen frischhaltefolie
jetzt das fleisch inzwischen der pole
geklopft damit einfach generiert und was
ich da ganz witzig finden wir essen
normalerweise immer ganz gerne wiener
schnitzel bei uns in ketsch da geht es
ein richtig tolles hotel und dort gibt
es die auch da gibt es glaube ich so die
besten schnitzel bei uns in der region
und wann hört dann immer aus der küche
wenn gerade die schnitzel schnitzel
gemacht werden weil dann kopfzahl in der
küche jetzt gibt's theorien und zwar
dass man mit der flachen seite glocken
sollte bei kalbsfleisch wahlkampfs
fleisch sowieso so zart ist und es durch
die raue seite würde man anscheinend das
gegenteil bewirken und es würde zu
werben
bei schweinefleisch nimmt man dann eher
dass hier habe ich gelesen ich muss
sagen ich hab die kalbsschnitzel bisher
auch immer so geklopft ich probier's
einfach mal andersrum als ich damit aber
die glatte seite 100 folie braucht ihr
damit zum eigentlich spritzt und zum
anderen schützt ist das fleisch und ja
es geht einfach ein bisschen besser
ich bereite immer gerne einen
kartoffelsalat mit gemüsebrühe zu und
dafür habe ich die kartoffeln jetzt hier
bereits gekocht etwas abkühlen lassen
geschält und in scheiben geschnitten die
gemüsebrühe wird dann noch warm über die
kartoffeln gegossen so dass sie wirklich
auch schon einziehen kann
danach kommen bei mir noch paprika
stücke mit rein conny chance mag ich
auch ganz gerne etwas schnittlauch und
natürlich auch angebratene zwiebeln und
das ganze wird dann noch mit essig mit
etwas salz und pfeffer gewürzt
alles was ich bisher gemacht habe können
die wunderbar vorbereiten also
kartoffelsalat richten fleisch klopfen
ab jetzt müsst ihr aber alles dann
machen wenn gegessen wird denn ein
schlüssel darf niemals vor paniert
werden und liegen gelassen werden
dann wird es nämlich nicht schön luftig
das heißt wenn jetzt alles bereit ist
auf dem tisch können da alles
vorbereiten ich brauche eine große
pfanne ich nehme jetzt hier die sanierer
pfanne die kurzreisen pfanne und werdet
ihr das öl rhein geben und es muss schon
ordentlich öl seien das schnitzel muss
darin schwimmen sogar noch etwas mehr
weil ich jetzt wirklich die große von
haare und jetzt kann ich es hier langsam
erwärmen gusseisen zeichnet sich auch
dadurch aus dass es langsam die hitze
annimmt und daneben auch schön ab gibt
also auch bei anderen fall und dürfen
niemals direkt auf 9 sondern wirklich
schön langsam hoch erhitzen und jetzt
werden hier die schnitzel erst einmal
gesalzen und gepfeffert
dafür nehme ich jetzt einfach die bühne
und damit ich jetzt nicht fleisch und
damit der mühle anfassen mache ich das
hier einmal vor
jetzt schön von beiden seiten salzen und
pfeffern
ich habe ich jetzt das mehl danach kommt
dass wir können es mit oder ohne sahne
machen
ich glaube da streiten sich auch die
geister ein bisschen jetzt hier kurz
erklären
und wie gesagt gerne noch die sahne
dazugeben und jetzt warte ich noch auf
das fett das feld ist jetzt warm etwa
zwischen 160 180 grad darf nicht zu heiß
sein damit die schnitzel ich zu braun
werden und ihr können testen ob es warm
genug ist mit einem holzstiel und wenn
sich daran direkt diese bläschen bilden
dann ist perfekt als etwas geht es
zuerst im mehl wenden werden solange
hier sagen wenn ich gut aber da ich kein
profi schnitzel zubereiter bin der das
jeden tag macht gehen auch diese kunden
schätzen die runden tiefen teller und
dann durchziehen und normalerweise mache
ich beim panieren immer so dass ich ein
schnitzel als eine trockene handhabe und
eine flüssige damit ich später keinen
schnitzel hände habe aber bei den großen
schnitzel funktioniert
da brauch ich beide hände
jetzt hier die panade so ein bisschen an
drücken was jetzt gleich mega wichtig
ist zum einen weg von euch in die pfanne
legen damit es kein fett auf euch
spritzt zum anderen muss die pfanne
natürlich groß genug sein
das ist hier reinpasst stellen rasch und
ich muss jetzt hier die fahren ja immer
mal rütteln damit die panade schön
luftig wird dann wird sie einmal gewesen
also ich warte jetzt bis die rückseite
schön goldgelb ist und dann wende ich
sie
und wisst ihr als schnitzel queen macht
man das was ich parallel am besten
wirklich in zwei pfannen auspacken
denn dann seid ihr wirklich viel
schneller fertig ist bei frank ohle
trinks auch wenn es da nämlich alles
schneller am tisch und wenn jemand beim
trainieren hilft dann geht noch
schneller
[Musik]
ich bin echt bisserl auf geeignete der
idealisten videos die ich jemals gesehen
habe wo ich jemals dabei sein durfte es
ging um ein absolutes leibgericht meine
frau kann es bezeugen
immer wenn irgendwo hingehen ich weiß es
ist leicht
zuerst immer ein italiener esse ich
immer spezieller rumpsteak mit pizza und
wenn ich sonst keine zeit gibt beim
italiener
und was ist mit der deutsch
österreichische küche möchte ich im
wiener stützen aber nur ist nur da muss
auch gut ist genau und ich möchte ganz
kurz paar geheimtipps geben ich glaube
ich jetzt bin ich in wien sei geht ihr
ins plachutta zu mario richtig genial
muss ich ganz ganz ehrlich sagen fliege
müller heißt ja glaub ich auch ist nicht
schlecht so schlecht
wer so die zweite woche zwei mal wenn
man es auch sagen dass weniger in der
nähe von wahlkreisen wohnt dann geht
ganz ganz wichtig geht ins seehotel
hotel und die ente dienten in ketsch ist
es soll zwischen wenn man jetzt war sie
nicht kennen so an mannheim mannheim
hockenheim hat karlsruhe nach ketzin ins
hotel
da in das restaurant die blaue in tester
widerstand die eltern genau
und da müsste das essen das ist so ja
ich habe erst gestern vorgestern wiener
schnitzel gegessen weil ein sternekoch
ging gar nicht muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagt ja ich sag dir nicht bei gehen aber
es ging gar nicht ich habe es noch mal
ganz kurz salz und verkauft denn ich
glaube ich habe ein bisschen zu wenig
gewürzt aber ich will das mal gespannt
wann wiener schnitzel machen das ist das
genial was es gibt und was luftig ja ich
möchte euch noch gar nicht sexistisch
sein möchten nicht sein und ich möchte
es auch keine sexismus debatte haben
aber ganz ehrlich jungs wenn eine frau
kein - schlüssel machen kann dann nach
seinem regal
dann heiratete nicht dann kann sie aber
jetzt gerade machen
genau wie den du heiraten willst mach
bitte ist jetzt einfach erfordern noch
in weitere fettnäpfchen tritt ist gut
ich liebe dich oder das netz geschlagen
haben so moment verpasst was fehlt salz
habe ich doch gesagt ich halte mir nicht
zu nur salz fährt bis hin zu sparsamen
sein so krass was die panade an
geschmack ausmacht und muss richtig luft
ich richtig locker sein
und es ist ja immer die wenn er die
sonne hoch nimmst du hast dich ja so am
stück ab dies schildau und das ist das
geheimnis und da merkt ja auch ob es
eine coole küche ist wenn der trick ist
bei der panade ist wichtig dass man sie
frisch macht und wenn sie nicht frisch
ist dann ist sie so körnig
dann klebt an und ganz ehrlich ohne spaß
und wiener schnitzel als fertiggericht
zu kaufen wirklich geht gar nicht das
ist es geht absolut nicht
guck mal hier danke ich hab schon noch
den karton lag da kann man sich streiten
ob man schwäbischen macht aber kein
schwäbischen macht mit gurken mit
zwiebeln aber ich clean ist mist das ist
lustig auf dem grat heute ist jetzt
macht sie gerade dieses wiener schnitzel
rezept und heute abend dem essen
gesamten team und wir gehen wie in der
schlüssel ist ja eigentlich kann das
abendessen auf jetzt verschieben
gabriel ich das machen und haben noch
weitere schnell zu also haltet euch an
die tipps und tricks hier aus dem video
probiert das wiener schnitzel gerne mal
auf und postet eure ergebnisse mit dem
ex tennis welt
wenn ihr auch ganz ganz sicher dass bei
euch jemand gibt ja das minus ist
richtig genial macht dann schreiben sie
kommentare vielleicht gibt es noch
weitere richtig coole tipps und tipps
und geheime restaurants die wir auch
nicht kann und dann schreibt gerne rein
also bis zum nächsten mal und schreibt
gerne auch in die kommentare
welches basic rezept ihr als nächstes
sehen wollen herr steigen so richtig
original schwedische rezepte die
herbekommen linken schwabe ein paar
geben
ich habe sowieso die ware ich nenne
jetzt die anderen fertig
mal zusammen
[Musik]